we always talk about like every
Corrections over correction right right
this is thing I hate is when people
start going this person had power over
them okay what kind of power like
physical power no they were a celebrity
and that person admired them and because
they admired him they were put in a
power position over them and that's why
it's considered sexual assault or sexual
misconduct yeah we're not talking about
underage girls we're talking about girls
at soccer right team that's [ __ ] and
I really think Louie kind of started
this when he gave his apology he goes
these women admired me and I took that
line of thinking before really was yeah
you're taking advantage of a power
dynamic which is just like underaged
illegal that guy belongs in the jail if
you are 25 and he's 28 and he's famous
and he sleeps with you and it's a power
dynamic what hot girl doesn't have a
power dynamic then that's the
conversation we should have right isn't
it power dynamics exists within sex
right and sex is a [ __ ] murky muddy
topic and it's really difficult talking
about and we are not on this podcast
gonna be the ones ago this is how you
have sex yeah these are the rules sex is
primal and we're in a civilized society
and those two don't mesh well that's a
great way of and what we're trying to do
as a great way putting it and what we're
trying to do is we recognize how primal
it is and we're stand we're trying to go
okay here is the course of action that
makes sense
there's a civilized way to have sex and
we literally doing it because we care
about women yeah we're like how can we
make sex the safest thing for women and
every once in a while we go too far
we're like we're just gonna ask you
every two minutes if it's okay yeah
layer do you still consent you still
consent and then women start going yeah
just [ __ ] me
yeah dude oh they're like but at first a
woman's like well actually I really like
that that's nice
so we overcorrect and then we come back
etc the power dynamic thing in sex is
very interesting for so many reasons and
we're having this discussion yesterday
there are so many different power
exchanges that exist within sex mm-hm
you know Marc brought up a good point
yes sir he goes the tricky thing about
power dynamic is like you can't turn
your power off so if you're a person
that is famous
by that rule you can't [ __ ] anybody that
likes you he has you have to [ __ ]
someone who's equally famous check it
even if they're equally famous what if
they admire you
yeah I can't [ __ ] I could only [ __ ]
people that that don't admire me yeah
yeah it's a it's an odd thing like Louis
literally said in his in his stupid
apology he goes you know these women
admired me and I took advantage of that
[ __ ] are you telling women they
should [ __ ] people they don't admire
that's only men do that it's the reason
we want to accomplish things is because
you're not gonna physically want to [ __ ]
most men so we try to do things out of
worth you admiring in some way yeah no I
like this guy's kind I like this guy's
art I like this guy's apartment even I
admire this guy's apartment yes
that's why we work hard that's like
evolution what about the second part of
his apology where he goes that he took
advantage of their admiration
what do you how is that taking advantage
of admiration and is that wrong if it's
a boss and an employee and the employees
worried she's gonna lose her job
I can understand that's a power dynamic
absolutely that's also sexual harassment
a law that's a great point you're making
right if it's a boss and someone they
work and works under them right yeah you
want to know if it was really equal
society if it was truly equal society we
were decent individuals that boss should
be able to hit on the person he works
with I'll tell you why interesting why
is that because if we respected when
women were like I'm not interested and
didn't hold it against them yet against
them and didn't have this [ __ ] ego
thing where now we want to punish them
not well it's like when the guy hits on
the girl on the street and then they
walk away and will [ __ ] you in [ __ ] hey
if we didn't have will [ __ ] you then
[ __ ] yeah in the office women wouldn't
be afraid to say no right and then they
could work together harm harmoniously to
me I think 90% of people meet at where
they work right but to me if you work
with someone and you find them beautiful
and then you start to like admire their
work ethic and you think they're really
intelligent and smart that's a way
deeper connection than some [ __ ] you
met at the [ __ ] bar they got a
miniskirt on [ __ ] you're like hey I'd
like to meet you or you wanna have a
drink of my table yeah
like now grated I like the rules that we
have in place in the workplace because I
don't think that men or women have the I
don't know like the the lack of like
emotional reaction to being rejected
yeah right so I want to protect women
and that Vollmer just don't hit on them
but if we were truly equal and treat
each other with true decency we would be
able to hit on the people we work with
in accept rejection so what the rule
does that make sense yeah so basically I
think the rules of sex would be a lot
clearer if everybody was okay with
rejection but since we're not and were
human beings yes everybody takes that
personally yes that's where the power
dynamic becomes scary so if somebody
that works underneath somebody's like no
I don't want to have sex with you then
that person that's a boss is like [ __ ]
you yeah check me stupid [ __ ] you'll
never do anything in this business I'm
gonna hold you down in this I can't
believe you that bruised my ego but if
the purse if we're all cool with
rejection it's you would you like to go
out no okay would you like to go out no
ok still I did say yes right because
then the opposite is that you have to
say yes and then there's where you get
girls that do stuff and they go I did it
but I didn't want to and then the
average person goes well why'd you do
something I didn't want to and then
they're like well I thought I was gonna
get fired I thought I never have a
career wrapped up in this power dynamic
that from the outside we observe and
we're like that's what's [ __ ] and I
get why we're trying to protect for that
because if that's your daughter you want
to protect her you don't want her bought
your boss hitting on your door I don't
even want my daughter to have a boss oh
no God tell him my girl what to do I
think we what's going on with that like
just go to write emails all day that's
actually true I was like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with my girls only had female
bosses in one gay dude and I loved that
guy oh you love this guy how [ __ ] up
his daddy's doing me like he's asking
her to order lunch for him mission she's
doing it I asked for a cup of waters
[ __ ] that gets us over what the [ __ ]
is going on it was evident you would not
do well at church but wait wait why the
priest or is talking yo yo chill chill
chill chill need communion
yo you don't need
put your tongue back in your [ __ ]
head
oh yes anyway so back to what we're
saying oh yeah so that pride power
dynamic and work [ __ ] up yes right
completely understood etc but then when
you take that same thing that we're
trying to protect from and then you
bring it into the world right where a
guy just happens to be famous and a girl
is attracted and admires that guy for
being famous and you go hey he can't
have sex with that girl because he has
this like there's this imbalance of
power there what people need to realize
is that like people let people men and
women leverage their power yeah a
beautiful woman is completely aware of
her power oh yeah and leans into that
power oh he gets pulled over you could
have any of our girlfriends would
probably be like you get pulled over
maybe there's like a wink or a smile hey
you want to pull up to a club you don't
want to wait on line you walk up to the
door and beautiful maybe I'm beautiful
enough to just get in and cut the line
doing it and we're not telling women you
shouldn't do that walk right in the club
that's why we there yeah we don't want
to wait in the line with us a power
dynamic I see a girl waiting on line for
the club I'm like is this a power
dynamic only exists is you is if if you
saying no I can affect your life like at
a job I can affect your life I'm a
teacher I can affect your grade your
life if I'm famous and I say no [ __ ]
leave like what am I what impact do I
have after this I think the only thing I
can think about in this case some of the
women or girls asked him if they can if
he can mentor them or whatever they were
interested in becoming comics no but no
but I'm just saying so that's where the
power dynamic would be because they're
like oh well if I don't agree to making
out or whatever he requested then he
won't train me to become a cop
yeah fine no but I'm just saying that's
where in this training is like no energy
but training is like it's not like a
tangible thing that leads a job there is
a salary that is set your promotions can
be in line like it's a set path you are
in this job finding another job is hard
if a guy doesn't want to mentor you okay
yeah
Big Sisters there's plenty of mentors
out there like I must understand we but
like we saying is that in that dynamic
maybe you could take advantage of that
relationship I don't believe that that's
the case and I also think that we need
to be like completely aware and this is
outside of that situation just any
situation it's really funny because I
disagree on on Whitney's Whitney had our
response and I disagree one part of
where she goes like a fan should be able
to DM what is it a fam to be able to DM
you know celebrity but I was teenage
girls should be able to DM and guy
shouldn't respond whole thing is that
I'll pull up the exact we though we can
no I think it's fans if it's teenage
girl she was referring to underage she
says in in the tweet ok pulling it up
the girls should be able to be a fan of
a comedian they admire without becoming
a sexual target I disagree disagree I
first of all I 100% yeah yeah I agree
yeah if you're a fan absolutely and
listen I'm saying this as someone who is
in a faithful relationship and has a
girlfriend I have nothing to gain from
this
I plan on marrying my girl I'm having
kids with her so all you [ __ ] out of
look that being said it's really
interesting when we saw these so I am
also faithful so all you [ __ ] are
very lucky that came out is this there's
this idea right I agree with that
statement in that way of course that
being said it doesn't necessarily
absolve you from it right so a lot of
these girls were like they deemed and
this is not just about Christa there's
just other situations right like people
DMing this that kind of stuff girls
complaining about DMS right yeah what
what is very interesting is like what I
took that as a criticism up is a girl
DMing a guy going oh my god you're so
funny or oh my god you're great tonight
etc and then going a girl basically she
go a girl should be able to do that and
it not be interpreted as anything
besides just you were congratulating you
on your show okay right I agree yeah my
question to you Akash is what your girl
agree that was the intention at @dm oh I
was waiting to see how you got out of
this one and you did it
I would ask you girls who says we should
just be on the DM and then nobody should
think anything of it
I would ask any girl who says that what
would you say if a girl DM your man what
would you think that I think that people
are abundantly aware of what dm's are
okay and and there's a song a go down
and a dear yes right we know what the
[ __ ] the DM is about and we know their
different ways some girls has come
straight out foot picks teenie picks
whatever some girls will be like hey
what's going on later tonight winky face
yeah I'm saying yeah right so it's like
I think we know what the [ __ ] DMS are
and some girls that they just want to
say great show we'll say hey me and my
boyfriend went to your show we had so
much fun
yep they throw a boyfriend in there to
let you know it's completely platonic
and low-key they might be saying that
and they go what are you guys doing
later that girl might be leveraging her
sexuality to hang out with you because
her boyfriend wants to the boyfriend
might be going hey he's not gonna
respond my DM because I'll have tits you
have tits use the power of your tits to
get that person to respond you're his
game my friend so now are you saying
they're like the DM is because there's
such an overt sexual tone in it yeah
that it's on the messenger to make it
clear what the intention I think is a
shared responsibility yeah yeah I think
it's one of those things where it's like
it's shared but it's not on anybody okay
but it's not absurd to assume that there
could be sexual content if you are
messaging me privately the understanding
is there's a reason you don't want this
public and maybe you're just shy and
sure we should all just assume that
you're just shy and it means nothing
a lot of times that's not what it means
and to Andrews point
our girls would not think it meant she's
just I would just ask girls what they
think the dm's are yeah if I'm
responding to random girls DMS my girls
came back yo what's good with that
and then I'm dead well I'm just respect
girls just the enemy is she literally
gonna go to Mesa Vicki are you so stupid
to think yeah the girls are just DM and
they don't want anything else yeah
like here's the thing a lot of people
replay boy for the for the [ __ ]
articles right yeah which already people
ain't looking at damn [ __ ] articles
hmm
I can't name one writer for Playboy yeah
I don't believe the words in Playboy
Yami can y'all name one writer for
Playboy like that was the thing that
people love these articles I don't know
single article no I didn't even know
there was article apparently the
interviews were kind of good and I'm
assuming they got the interviews by
being like hey you could [ __ ] any one of
these girls use in interviews I guess I
guess what I'm trying to say is like
like like the way you weren't there is a
shared responsibility that we all have
for the murky waters that is the sexual
exchange it's mysterious it's dangerous
and it's uncomfortable and I want women
to be the most comfortable they possibly
can be in those situations I truly do
okay that's not to say that there aren't
[ __ ] Psychopaths out there and
they're sociopaths out there they're
like womanizing and doing [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] and being real pieces of
[ __ ] to women you can [ __ ] a lot of
girls and date a lot of girls without
being a horrible piece of [ __ ] to them
hmm yeah you know you can also [ __ ] a
lot of girls and date a lot of girls and
be really good too the vast majority of
them and then [ __ ] up and be a piece of
[ __ ] to a couple of them you know you
could also not [ __ ] that many girls and
still be a piece of [ __ ] like yeah like
y'all can you like could you clarify one
part like yeah I think that people with
power could use their power in order to
manipulate a young impressionable person
in order like you exploit them for sex
yeah you could of course you could yeah
what define young and impressionable so
like you're 18 you DM someone you're
like oh you're really funny and then a
famous person could use their power and
soul to have sex with them well III 100%
I agree with that and then you could I
will say this though we
have to decide an age when women are
women and we got to stop infantilizing
women if an 18 year old woman is old
enough to be sent to Iraq to go to war
right if she's been all she's old enough
to give her life for the United States
of America she's old enough to get a DM
if she's old enough to get a $400,000
loan that will [ __ ] her financially
for the rest of her life for college
she's old enough to get a DM right like
we can't infantilize women when we want
because we removed their agency and we
removed their power when we're just
trying to create these like little
bumpers like they have a bowling say
like their agency this guy said I ain't
got no agent that's the problem with a
lot of it by Jason Steinberg so it is a
weird situation where it's like yeah you
can create all these rules to protect
women and we could take the age and we
could decide what it is but if you could
vote for the United States President of
the United States if you can go to war
if you can get a [ __ ] huge bank loan
if we can give you insane responsibility
at 18 years old that's the assumption
that you are mature enough to handle it
you should be mature enough to handle a
[ __ ] VM yeah and if we don't think
women are mature enough at 18 let's make
that wall and let's pass that law 21 21
I'm 35 I don't care what it is whatever
you guys think it is or whatever the
country thinks it is let's do that let's
do that but it's 18 and I don't care if
your state says 17 or 16 naw I don't
care if 17 or 16 is legal in your state
it's 18 mmm in the court of public
opinion is 18 yeah if you go under 18
don't give me wolves in Colorado
no yeah yeah no you are after young
girls they actually got to be a national
law yeah we can't have this state to
state I mean what is that
that's great Mississippi I think 16 have
you [ __ ] 16 year olds Oh technicality
there's some state is like 14 or
something you can get married in New
Hampshire at 12 or something like that
what is going on that's not even bar
mitzva age
yes well if it ain't even a bot yeah
that's adoption
that's just adoption I think anyway so I
think that is an important conversation
we have I think these in conversations
really important I hope this sheds a
little bit of light on like why guys are
frustrated and I hope that we
articulated why we get frustrated and
kind of like scared from these me two
movements but also I hope it shed some
light on why the sexual experience from
women is [ __ ] terrifying
yeah because literally every girl has
had a horrible experience sexual that's
a good point you don't say and and I'm
not trying to like she's not horrible
like he was see sucking been horrible
like oh [ __ ] this is terrible you're
coerced or whatever I'm too drunk I
might be raped something might like that
is a normal thing that women have had to
experience in their life yeah and we
never have had to experience that yeah
so it's hard for us to even calculate
and also if you're a [ __ ] decent guy
it's not even coming into your brain
yeah that you would want to rape a girl
yeah you don't say I'm too insecure for
that I like when a crowd you know these
comics that bomb a lot we all watch you
enjoyed knows too much boo and no
similar bro I'm seeing you at a show
when someone fell asleep because they
were so drunk and you yelled at him you
were like yeah what are you doing wake
up so just a slice of thing like you
agree that someone could use their power
in an abusive way in order to manipulate
someone to have sex but just because
someone leverages their power in a
sexual relationship does not mean it's
abuse yes and I think someone exists
both male and female I think there are
females that will will I think there are
men that can abuse their power yeah
especially you know in certain
industries where women really want to
get into that in distress [ __ ] though
and that's [ __ ] and I and I know for a
fact famous women who have done that to
men who are very famous right now famous
right so I think people use their power
to get what they want and sometimes that
sex and I think that's abusive and I
think that's [ __ ] up
yes I also think there are ways where
like
people are using their power to engage
in you know to get the most out of the
situation they're in right so there are
girls that might use their sexual power
to get some free drinks but they'll just
kind of walk up to a bottle service
table and those guys are using their
financial power to have bottles so that
girls walk up to the table and that
exchange is good as long as both parties
are cool with it sure I mean I'm ok with
that stuff in that you have to slice
morality on this girl's getting free
drinks and it's like I gives a [ __ ]
really you know what I mean like yeah so
in conclusion let's kind of wrap this
discussion up the reality is we're not
gonna sit here and go these are the
rules for sex 1 because there's no women
here so we need to know one how they
feel - you guys haven't had enough sex
with multiple people to even really talk
about it right so you don't even with
the one person so like we're not gonna
go and say that and that's a longer
discussion and a discussion that needs
to be had with tons of different guys
and girls together and mapping out all
the different possibilities and how we
would interact with those things it is a
dark and murky and like akash said I
think you describe the best primal
activity that we are trying to put
makeup on and class up and make safe for
everyone involved yeah because I really
do think the majority of guys do not
want to [ __ ] make a girl feel
uncomfortable yeah and I think the
majority of girls do not want to me to a
guy they don't ever want to be even put
in a situation where they would feel
like they'd have to yeah and maybe we're
afraid to talk about sex publicly
because you know we might have these
like judeo-christian values that make
sex seem taboo and it's a weird
conversation to have but we need to have
the [ __ ] conversation yeah and I
think it's good that we're having these
conversations and I hope the thing that
comes out of this is a more equitable
and safer environment for sex for
everybody for everybody
[Applause]
you